Um, how much did you learn about racing from your dad?
Hardly nothing, man. I mean, we, uh,
obligate asked all the time what your dad taught you about X, Y, and Z.
And we never talked about racing. Um, really never. Wow. Yeah.
We never talked about reason. You started racing professionally? Yeah. Wow.
Yeah, we never did. Um, he was always,
uh, don't, you know, finish.
He was so worried that me and Kelly wouldn't finish school,
that we would give up on school.
He gave up on school as an eighth grader at 16 years old.
He was 16 in eighth grade and quit and never finished high school.
Never got no GED, nothing.
And people would come up to him and say,
our people would talk about him. Um, even while he was lab and ever since.
And, uh, say,
look what this guy made of himself having quit the eighth grade.
That's awesome. And he always hated that. That was embarrassing, uh,
for people to S you know, he was embarrassed that he quit.
He knowed how bad it disappointed his own father.
So he was always like worried about where I was,
who I was hanging out with, whether I was, you know, doing my homework.
And then even when I started racing, it was who I was hanging out with,
what I was doing with my free time, what I was focusing on, whether I was,
you know, thinking about, you know, what I was,
whether it was on time for sponsor appearances and never is how you drive this
corner. This is, I get around this race track. He never talked about this stuff.
It was always the person being a man, being right,
being good to people, being on time, being ready to work,
uh, looking your best. Um, general, you know,
morals and values. He didn't,
we never sat down and talked about racing like true.
You had to get around this corner and this is how you shift and shit like that.
Well, in that respect it was probably brilliant of them. Cause look,
the championships came and you also turned out to be a great man.
Ah, thanks. I appreciate you saying that. I, uh,
I don't know. I always felt like that when I was younger,
I kind of let my father down because, um,
there was this one time I was probably 12 years old and there was this,
me and my buddy, we were going to play, man, we're here, we're outside,
we're going to play outside.
My dad's standing over there and there was a bucket full of shit. And he's like,
Hey, come here Pope junior, pick that bucket up, move it over here.
And I went over there and tried to pick it up and I was like, I can't lift it.
And he got so pissed off at me cause he knew I didn't try any gay.
He said to my buddy, Ryan, he goes, Ryan, come here,
pick the bucket up and take it over there.
And he turned around and gave me this look of pure freaking disappointment and I
felt like that set the tone for our relationship. Wow.
For one bucket. I know, I feel like that, that was the,
uh,
that was our relationship in a nutshell for most of my teenage years.
You know, he looked at me as, you know,
I don't know what he's going to Mount to.
I don't know what this kid is going to do. I don't know what, what, you know,
what skills he has or what is he going to ever get his act together or whether
he's ever going to figure himself out. You know.
And I probably didn't give him much reason to think different. Um,
but then when we got, when I started racing, um,
when I started racing it, uh, light models,
I ran 159 races and he never came to one, uh,
through 94 95, 96, 97. I raced at Myrtle beach,
South Carolina every weekend and he never once came down there to watch me.
And so he didn't know whether I was a good race car driver or a bad race car
driver. He didn't know whether I was, you know,
working on my car or understanding how they, you know, what, what,
how to build the car, fixed the car. And when I would do good,
I'd come home and I'd have a trophy and I'd say, Hey man, I won. And he'd go,
well, who wasn't there? And I'm like, shit,
he really did the first I remember coming home with a trophy and I could not
wait til he wa he would walk. I kept my car in this, uh,
in this building that was his, and he put all his deer head up, air,
caught a deer hit shop. I'm talking 35, 40 miles in this place, a couple of elk.
And uh,
he'd come in there every Monday morning before lunch and I had that trophy
sitting up. We'd brought it home, man, it was right in view.
Soon as he walks in,
I got my car working on my car and he comes in there and I'm like,
am I? He's like, so you want, huh? So he's a trophy. I was like, yeah,
we did. And he's like such and such must not been there.
Cause there was this one guy named Robert Powell,
he used to beat us all the time and he goes, Robert bus not been there.
I was like, no, he wasn't. He wasn't there. You're right. I was so pissed off,
man.
I finally won a damn race and I thought he was going to come in there and slap
me on the back and man, you know, give me, give me a good talk, um,
and give you more motivation that he didn't do that. I don't think so.
I don't think it did. I think it made me,
it did not make me want to win more. Um,
but then one day,
so right around the end of 1997,
I was out of money. He was like, Hey, you know, you're out of money.
You ain't gonna race. I was like, shit, my life is coming to an end.
As far as I know it, you know, I'm not gonna I guess my racing career, this is,
it is, it's coming to an end. 1997. Um,
he was sitting down and talking to, uh,
he had a car that races in the Xfinity series that I told you about on Saturdays
and he,
his driver was leaving to go to a cup car and he was talking to his best friend,
Tony sr is the guy's name that actually crew chiefs that car. And he's like,
who we're going to get drive his thing. Well who should we get?
We got a higher driver and Tony sr said, why don't you put Dale jr in here?
He goes, what? Are you serious? You really think so? He's like,
you're going to spend a little money on this car.
Why don't you spend it on your own kid? You know, why don't you just put ma,
I can, I can probably make a driver out of him. Tony sr says so
and so. They made a decision to put me in this car in the infinity series.
You'd think that dad would come tell me or we would have press conference,
not be a press release. At least I walked into,
this was a month before the race season starts.
I think I'm out of or I think I'm out of racing. Right. I ain't,
I ain't even talk to anybody about what I'm racing or if I'm racing in a couple
of months. I think that it's dried up opportunities. You're gone.
I'll walk into the shop to get something where Tony and senior's car,
Tony's Sr's race car was and my name was on the roof and I was like,
I thought it was a joke, like a mean joke, a prank. And they were laughing,
Tony sr and, and uh, some of the guys in the shop are laughing and I'm like,
man, that's messed up man.
Y'all are dicks for putting that name on there to say no funny in there.
And they were like, it's true, man. I was like,
you mean I'm going to race this car? I'm nice in this car. And they were like,
yeah. I was like, really? And uh,
I mean obviously I was thrilled. Like, man, I couldn't believe it,
but this is the way I found out, not from my own dad.
And I'm like, dad, I'm racing the car. Yup. I mean,
not days later when I seen him, I'm like, so I'm going to race that car.
And he's like, yup, yup, sure. Bear, get ready. And yeah,
and I mean it was, he was the strangest dude when it came.
He didn't, he didn't really.
But once I started racing that car and I had had great success,
we won six or seven races the first year we won another six or seven races the
second year of championships in both seasons.
So I made the choice to put me in that car,
worked out better than he probably ever imagined ever in 159 late model races
that I ran from 94 to 97 I won four in 159 late model races.
I won four.
So he put me in this car on a whim and a prayer and we ended up winning
championship two in a row. So he is thinking, damn,
this little yo shit can drive a car.
And that's when our relationship completely changed.
That's when I hit his arm around me. We were doing shit together.
We were brewing, we were doing, we had sponsored deals and promotions together.
We were doing photo shoots together.
I saw him all the time and we talked about all kinds of, you know,
we talked about life, um, girls and and everything, but racing, you know,
we didn't talk about race in much but just fine. But, um, it was awesome.
And so not eight, nine and nine and then 2000 I went to cup. He, he,
he built a cup team around me. We had Budweiser come in for $10 million a year,
which was the biggest sponsorship anybody had. And at that time, um,
in, uh, so,
and then he got killed in 2001 at the start of the season in Daytona 500.
So those three years, nine, eight, nine, nine,
2000 were as good as it could get. Wow. Yeah.
That must've been amazing.
It must have been amazing for you to turn that corner. Yeah.
It was like a light switch he went from,
he went from not really engaging with me,
me not comfortable around him feeling ashamed. Um,
not me, not measuring up. He's,
cause he's 10 foot tall cowboy boots, black hat, tougher and shit.
N***a,
you know intimidator that was his nickname and I was blonde,
pale short as hell,
not a muscle on me and had accomplished nothing,
you know, and so it,
but it overnight it was like completely changed.
We started running great and people were coming up to me,
I'm like, dude, you're freaking, you're doing awesome. And you know,
and he's, and he was, uh, he was real happy with that. He was pretty proud.
It's crazy that he never talked to you about race. No. That's just so strange.
Yeah, I can't imagine that was one, there was only one time that he did that.
We were at a track called Bristol, Tennessee. We were,
we were at a track in Bristol, Tennessee. Uh,
it's a half mile high banked race track and we run 15 second laps around there.
It's really fast and it's, it's kinda technical and tough to get around. Um,
and I had been race, I'm out there practicing and I wasn't,
I wasn't doing it right. And he got up on the, uh,
he got up on one of the haulers and got on the radio and started talking to me
and he was like, Hey man, I'm gonna tell you how to drive it.
And so this one day, one time in this one practice for about five minutes,
he's like, I'm gonna tell you how to drive his track. So I'm out there driving.
And um, when, uh, he's like,
I lift right here and I lift and he getting the gas. Okay,
I'm turn area and he's just telling me how to drive the track.
And that was the only time he ever did that to just think of how much it would
have improved. I know it really helped me there that day. I mean like his,
when he told me how to do it, I'm like, Holy shit,
this is way I would have never thought of doing it this way and this is way
better. Right. You know? So yeah.
Maybe you could have given me a few more tips on some things.
I mean come on man.
You mean that's how that has to be so crazy.
Cause that's your profession and your dad is a superhero.
You know, I finally made it to cup and I think had he lived,
he would have been in my ear all those years, you know, do this, do this,
don't do this. It's the best decision today. Um, so maybe he just didn't,
wasn't in a hurry to do it cause he didn't know that he wasn't going to be
around for it, you know.
How hard was it the race after he was gone?
How thought about whether I should quit or not? Um,
you know, I, I probably if the,
if it hadn't a paid a lot of money and I didn't have partners and people that
were dependent on me or counting on me,
I probably could have easily walked away from it.
But we had a great partner in Budweiser that was incredibly supportive.
Mmm.
I had a lucrative opportunity in front of me personally to be a,
be a race car driver for as long as I wanted to, which I wanted.
And I just had to go through missing him really bad for a few months. You know,
I had to, I had to go to the race track and everywhere I looked, you know,
there's dad, there were P, you know, fans morning.
Uh,
there were signs and paintings and things, you know,
there was just markings and acknowledgements and just shit everywhere for like a
year. Uh, and I appreciated it and I knew why it was like that.
Um, but it took a while for me to, uh,
sorta get to where I didn't. Um, I was, I went,
there was a little period of me,
the period of time where I was real self destructive and just like a mad,
you know, everything. And um, you know,
took me awhile to calm down and get to work, you know, for, for,
for awhile there it was just sort of going through the motions,
the, you know, I mean, you must have always known, I mean,
everyone knows there's dangers involved in racing cars,
but when it hits someone so close as your own father that had to change what
racing felt like to you.
Mm. Yeah. I'm sure.
I'm sure it would have completely been a different experience. Um,
emotionally had that not happened, had, you know,
racing for me would have meant something completely different. Um,
you know, I just was, he was in, he was a, this,
he was this invincible God that, you know,
wasn't supposed to get hurt, wasn't supposed to. I mean, he was, he, he was,
he was supposed to get hurt and drive, hurt and be tough and, um,
he wasn't supposed to get keeled and leave us all, you know,
he left the whole sport, you know, and, and no one knew what to do.
Like that was like, the whole sport was sitting there going, shit,
what do we do? You know, he was the guy for everyone.
And even in, even the competitors, you know, looked up to him like he was the,
yeah, like that, that's the man and [inaudible]. Uh,
so it was tough on the whole sport to big Jack Boyd for the whole sport.
Um, but I, you know,
we just, uh, huddled together, me and my team, me and our company, we, you know,
rice for my dad's company. So that whole company kinda just kinda held,
held itself together and everybody kind of pulled,
pulled together and worked our way through it.
That first year in Oh one just that year, you know, that he was killed.
That that was just a kind of a tough year.
I don't even really remember anything much about what happened that year.
Um, won a couple of races. Uh, but it was a, otherwise,
you know, the races where we didn't win. I can't even,
I don't even remember much about them, you know,
just retaining too much from it. It was just kind of a days, you know,
Oh four was a great year.
I think we kind of finally were coming out of the funk, you know,
around 2004 kind of coming out of the cloud of that.
I would imagine that being a race car driver and have your dad be who he was
always carried a lot of weight, but did he carry more weight after he was gone?
Were there more eyes on you? Yeah, I thought so. Um, you know, I thought he,
he was tough. He knew who he was.
To the sport. And he knew, he knew that, you know,
he carried a,
he carried a big massive fan base and he knew that people listen to when he
spoke and all those things. And so when he was gone, I think some people,
some people kind of looked at me to try to carry that same load and even be that
same person. And I just wasn't gonna do it. Um, I was like, man,
I'm going to be me. I'm going to be the PR, you know, like I said, he was,
he's this 10 foot tall black hat and I'm, I'm this short,
scrawny pale kid. You know, I was,
I couldn't be who he was.
I'd have been faking it and I couldn't be the intimidator, you know,
so I just have always, ever since then
banned me and if that's good, if you'd like that. Um, great.
Uh, I think I've been relatable, honest, genuine. Um,
and the fan base that I gained when he passed away,
I thought we nurtured that and grew that.
And I think we did a lot of great things, uh, and,
and outside the to, uh, to do that.
Um, so I'm kind of proud of all those things.
I thought I handled that well. Um,
considering there are a lot of different avenues to go at that time and I think
I chose some good ones and certainly probably could have made some different
decisions and have regrets.
But for the most part I was able to, you know,
add to his legacy a little bit. That was something that was important to me.
I didn't go out there and win 90 day on races. I didn't win seven championships,
but I didn't hurt his legacy. I added to it, uh,
made a lot of people happy. Uh, there was an Earnhardt on the track,
you know, that was good for a lot of people deal.
You got a great perspective. Well, thanks.